okay i want to thank the workshop
organizers for putting this together
um
so
i have to apologize this is work in
progress there's no there's certainly no
theorem in complexity theory and there
may or may not be a theorem in math by
the end of the talk
but nonetheless
i think the there's
some ideas i'd like to present and a
general context
of how to use algebraic geometry to
prove lower bounds
and i want to advertise this both to
advertise the algebraic geometry
and for computer scientists and to
advertise the computer science for the
algebraic geometers so there's a lot of
very interesting problems and complexity
theory but just to fix ideas i'm just
going to focus on the flagship problem
of determinant versus permanent
so we have this determinant polynomial
and this permanent polynomial
and for the moment let's both be for n
by n matrices so these are a homogeneous
polynomial of degree n
on the space of n by n matrices
uh so maybe i'll write that as s n of e
tensor f
so this is also homogeneous polynomial
on space of n by n matrices
so e and f
are just
cn
and
you can if you like and i like
to define this
as the unique
polynomial
well
this is my talk i can have it be
polynomials on e tensor f star
um
invariant
under
left and left and right multiplication
by deter matrices with determinant one
so i'll write that as s l e cross s l f
so s l n is the space of n by n matrices
with determinant one
and that
this is unique
mathematicians use exclamation point for
unique
so it is characterized
by its symmetry group
and so complexity theorists tell us that
determinant is best polynomial
and
we all believe that as mathematicians
but
here is a representation theoretic
reason why it's a best polynomial it is
characterized by its symmetry group
and to mathematicians the permanent so
complexity theorists believe permanent
is a beautiful polynomial
as a mathematician it took me a long
time to warm up to the permanent but it
does also have this beautiful property
that you can simply define it as the
unique i'll write unique
unique i may even spell it correctly a
polynomial up the scale
well of course we already used up our
favorite group of left and right
multiplication by determinant one
matrices so i can't have the same
conclusion
so let's think about um other nice
things we could do well instead of
arbitrary matrices with determinant one
what about permutation matrices
and that's what this one is
and i'll write it like this
so this is permutation matrices
acting on the left and these are
permutation matrices acting on the right
and it's the only polynomial it is
characterized by its symmetries
so
and representation theory
we can agree
that these are
magnificent polynomials
questions
okay now the flagship conjecture
if i swap two rows of a matrix its
determinant changes
the torah stage keeps it involving a
tough determinant but the torah subject
of minute one keeps it in violence
you need to reciting yeah
yes
it's also invariant under the taurus but
it's already characterized by this group
he's not giving us
no that's not true oh so i need that
you need to
sorry
so these are the diagonal matrices or if
you like
the normal
the normalizer of the torai
yes when the determinant is invariant
another group then square will also be
invariant under that group
of unique polynomial in this vector
space
that is invariant under that group
right
no there are many polynomials
in different spaces in variant under
that group with different
representations
we're talking about embedded
so the flagship conjecture of geometric
complexity theory is
that you cannot write the permanent
so here m is less than n
is the lit as
a linear combination of determinants or
even in the orbit closure
when
n is some polynomial
m so m is less than n in this talk i
apologize
we should not go down too much because
okay i will not go down anymore
so um it's known
uh okay
when um
n is less than m squared over two
so at least it's known for a quadratic
polynomial with some constant
and um that result
uh
in mathematics
i i think computer scientists are not
aware that
there's actually slightly stronger
results than that
namely um
the way one tries to prove this
conjecture
is to find
a polynomial that vanishes on this set
that does not vanish on this point
or a module of polynomials because
we want to use
our group actions so i draw sort of a
cartoon picture here
to explain
the result that implies this
so
there were some
a module of polynomials
round sorry union green
so we found a module of polynomials on
the space of all polynomials on space of
degree n on space of matrices
and the zero set of this module
contained what we wanted the green
and it also contained some garbage
and the full theorem
is that not only does it contain the
green plus garbage but that the garbage
stays away from the
the green near the determinant that is
that there's a neighborhood a euclidean
ball about the determinant without any
garbage in it
that is
another way to say it is that this is an
irreducible component of the zero set of
these this module of equations so it's
stronger than just a bound here but
that's not the subject of today's
lecture but somehow complexity theorist
is exponential
the dimension of the garbage is
yeah it's exponential but small
exponential whatever that means
um
all right so let me let me write down
what i said because it's so important
the method
of attack
is find
g l n squared
modules
of polynomials
vanishing
on the determinant
and not
on
the permanent
okay that's the that's the plan okay
and
um what i'd like to talk about today
are
some
promising approaches
to this plan
so first i'm going to review
a method um first used by kyle and then
used extensively in this four author
paper you heard a little bit about it
last night
called the method of shifted partial
derivatives
and then i'd like to explain two
different generalizations
and i'm going to talk about it in the
context of this particular problem but
you should think of those
generalizations as being potentially
useful for arbitrary circuit lower bound
problems any time you have a complexity
class
an algebraic complexity class that can
be characterized by a polynomial that's
characterized by its symmetry
these kind of methods uh
are hopefully applicable
right so let's get started
so the good news is i got a new pen the
bad news is it doesn't want to erase it
so it marks it well
all right
so uh before
i explain the method of shifted partial
derivatives i should go back in time a
little bit
uh to explain the method of partial
derivatives so if you're a mathematician
i have to go back in time
well if you're a computer scientist i
have to go back in time to the 1990s
it was pioneered in computer science by
nissan and wigderson but if you're a
mathematician you have to go back to the
1800s it was uh pioneered by sylvester
who called it who gave it the funny name
of catalecticants and then later it
picked up some other names as people
rediscovered it one of which is
flattenings which is the one i tend to
use
i don't know why
i think that was barren to
coin that one so um i'm gonna have a
vector space
and i'm going to have a homogeneous
polynomial of degree n on the dual of
the vector space
so just homogeneous polynomial of degree
n in capital n squared variables
and we consider
the following linear map
let me call it p k
n minus k
so this
is if you like
the um space of homogeneous differential
operators of order n minus k
on this vector space
so a differential operator
will map to map a polynomial here to a
polynomial of degree k
and the image
is all
partials
of order
equal to k
all partials of p
so
if you have a lower bound on the rank of
this map you have a lower bound on the
complexity of your polynomial p
so
so if so we get polynomials on the space
of polynomials
so the size
r plus one minors
of this linear map
give polynomials
on the space of polynomials
degree r plus 1
because the entries of the matrix of
this linear map
are linear in the coefficients of the
polynomial so the total degree is r plus
1.
okay so let's do some examples
if p is just x to the n
what is r
the rank
of p k
n minus k is equal to one
r is the rank of this linear map
if
p is
a monomial
the rank is equal to
n choose k you get the most bang when
you take k about n over two this is like
two to the n over square root of n
when p is the determinant
uh we get um n choose k squared
so four to the n
roughly
and then um
so i should say
the possible
yeah i should say p generic
the rank
is um
capital n
plus
k minus one choose k
so um if in this space when n
is equal to n squared
then this that number would be n squared
plus k minus 1 choose k
and when p is the determinant this
number is quite a bit smaller than this
number the determinant is pathological
what is the image of the map it's just
the minors of size k because you take
derivative of a matrix
you know you have laplace expansion of
determinant
any questions
okay so the first unfortunate piece of
news for this technique
is the permanent
ties the determinant
and for the exact same reason because
you have laplace expansion
and so we need to do a little more if we
want to distinguish them at all
so let's take this map and try and beef
it up a little bit
so let me
let me um draw it like this
so can i ask this
i have not discussed young flattening
yet yes
that's part three
we're on part two i promise you i will
tell you part three
okay
so we have to beat this up so what i'm
going to do is just tensor this with the
space of polynomials of degree t
and for the moment do nothing
and now there's a
natural map if i have a homogeneous
polynomial of degree k in a homogeneous
polynomial of degree t
i can multiply them
to get a homogeneous polynomial of
degree k plus t
and this
is the um shifted partial derivatives
map
so in
gks
this is denoted i better tell you how
it's denoted because
it's um
this i i have unfortunate not only do i
reverse n m i'm reversing k and n minus
k this is denoted d equals n minus k
p
equals t
and i just want to
bring to your attention that this is
this is n minus k not k here i it's just
bad habits i have i'm a little dyslexic
that's only for the experts for kyle the
rest of you don't don't worry about that
so you don't need this
unless you want to connect with last
night's talk
so let's go through our examples
i erased the first example i just have
to erase the answers they change a
little bit
so how is this so p generic yes
how is this speaking minuscule defined
what oh you just i composed two linear
maps the one we've been discussing with
the multiplication map
okay so p generic you get the whole
space oh
oh oh oh yeah k
less than or equal to n minus k
uh even before i needed that
uh to not be lying
i forgot to say that
so um
so oh oh i should tell you what this is
as far as a geometer is concerned
uh geometrically
oh you don't want me to write this far
down okay
geometrically what am i doing
geometrically
call the image
of p n minus k
k the
n minus k
jacobian ideal
of p
and let
i
p
k denote the ideal it generates
denote
ideal
it generates
then the rank of this linear map
is the hilbert function
of the ideal not of the coordinate ring
of the ideal
in degree k plus t
so i'm trying to be as bilingual as i
can but i don't uh properly speak
computer science and i later in the talk
you'll see i also don't properly speak
community of algebra so i may have to
get corrected once in a while by the
experts but
this ideal
so for every k in every t
i get a linear map okay now let's fix k
and allow t to vary
what the images of this these linear
maps are are exactly the component of
the ideal in degree k plus t
and therefore the rank of this linear
map is nothing as a function of t is
nothing other than the hilbert function
of that ideal generated in degree k
so um if it's generic it's subjective so
the rank is n plus
k plus t minus 1 choose k plus
t
if for this one
it's n plus k minus 1
choose k because if i take an nth power
and i
if i start with a k power
this multiplication map is an injection
and has no kernel and i'll return to
that issue later that actually will be
kind of sadness for us
in this case
um
this
sort of known to the experts but we
couldn't find it written down
the rank
is um this
sum of binomial coefficients
and i i'll say it now because i won't
have time later we actually have the
full minimal through resolution which is
also
sort of fairly standard if you know
stanley theory
um
so the determinant has an interesting
story
um there's a classical answer
which is not so useful
but i'll write it down
well it's useful for a particular k in a
particular t
but if you're a computer scientist as
i've learned you want to do asymptotics
and then this
is a little hard
to compute
so
the the ideal is known very explicitly
um it starts out with the size k minors
and you pick up
all polynomials
in sim and of
sim k plus t
in e tensor f you pick up so this is
splits as a direct sum of a whole bunch
of s pi e's tensor s pi f's where pi
ranges over all partitions of k plus t
and the ones that are in the ideal are
the ones where the number of rows of the
partition the number of skew symmetries
is k because you started out with k by k
minors
so you have to keep those skew
symmetries you can't get rid of them
um so that's nice but hard to work with
and then um sternfels
has a a more effective
way using grobner bases to estimate
well he has an exact answer
and it is a good tool for estimation
unlike now the writing for the debt and
permanent the this
dimension of pk rank of pk minus kt
is that what you're writing yes yes
yes i'm still on the determinant
i'm still on the determinant and now let
me tell you something that's worse than
sturm phil's
um
for for just this particular question
but it will be more important later
lascu and made more explicit by weiman
um
is i'm not even going to write it down
it's a
description in terms of
alternating sums of products of binomial
coefficients so already this is bad that
this is an alternating sum
this is a sum of products of binomial
coefficients and then you can make it
even worse by making an alternating sum
but
we'll see that that actually has more
information in it later in the talk
and then for p equals the permanent
the rank
well this is not known properly
if k equals two
it can be deduced
from work of
one
and swanson
around 2000
and for k equals three can be deduced
from work of cure cop
in 2008
and more on this later
when i talk about minimal free
resolutions i'll i'll give you a little
bit more information about that
now uh now i have some
bad news for the computer scientists
this won't really be hard news because
i think this was known
qualitatively before
but the quantitative result
is sad
one does not know an answer for the
arbitrary king that is correct and part
of this talk the last part of this talk
will be progress towards that question
so here's the unhappy proposition
um
if m is less than n over 2
then
oh i forgot
yes one more shifted partial
oh i'll write it up here
this is an important one
uh
gk kkks
if p is equal to sum of two monomials
uh
the rank
of this linear map is at least
the sum
j equals 0 to n minus k
n
k minus j
k plus t
minus 1 k plus j minus 1.
i hope i got that right
oh no no that's the wrong one that's the
wrong one that's the other that's that
one sorry i thought that looked funny um
there's no sum in there that's why
theirs is nice because there's no sum
it's 2 n minus k
choose 2 n minus 2 k
times n squared plus t
minus 2 n plus k
which is t
this n squared that is come from what n
squared is the number of variables n is
a number in this polynomial n is the
number yes but i'm considering this
inside sim n of c n squared and it just
happens to use only two n of the
variables thank you
y and y n are separate from x one x
that's correct
n squared is capital n so i'm
considering this just like we do for the
permanent
as a polynomial in a bigger space that
only happens to use a few of the
variables
a few no meal i think you guys call it
something like that okay well whatever
you call it okay but
anyway
few monomials thank you
see i told you i need corrections for
both languages yes
they calculated is for determinant but
no they calculated it for this
and they stated it for determining but
the proof they used that polynomial
okay
so this is in their proof
if not in their statement but it's funny
that they had no sum but for a single
one there is some
well that's because this is an estimate
and this is an exact answer that's an
asymptotics
that's an estimate that's asymptotics
but it's a sharp estimate that in the
sense that it's true for every nk and t
within the admissible range
but it's just an estimate it's not exact
i missed that yeah that's why it's
greater than or equal to
right but unfortunately using so using
that result
um
if
n is less if m is less than n over 2 and
remember we want it to be
at least smaller than square root of n
to say something new
um then shifted partial derivatives
cannot show
that l to the n minus m p
is not contained in the gln squared
orbit closure of that polynomial
for all p
with the rank
that looks like the permanent
you mean n squared by 2 or n by
n by 2
that's that's why the frown if it was n
squared over 2 i'd be delighted because
i
we the rest of this talk is going to be
about going beyond shifted partial
derivatives and if shifted partial
derivatives could equal the old world
record we'd be throwing a party i mean
that that'd be awesome but unfortunately
that's not the case
so let me finish this statement
for with for all p with rank this
and in particular
in particular
the permanent
perm and see this thing sits inside this
is a degeneration of the determinant
so the same thing is true for the orbit
closure of the determinant
right
so that's bad news
sorry to be bearer of bad i didn't want
to erase that let me
so what's it say because
what
yeah but we want to separate permanent
from determinant
and this says we cannot do it by this
method
yeah that's within that range but i
agree the method all the same
proposition could be used to prove that
you cannot separate
the padded determinant from the padded
but we don't that's not our problem we
got enough problems in our life
we don't need to add to them so let me
keep this on the board
eraser happy
all right so the um
els region okay this preposition is els
yes
yes
so 2015 paper
um
and it may even become elsw but that's
for the last part of the talk
um
right so we want to
go further
so let me tell you a parallel world
so
these equations whatever these equations
are shifted partial derivatives
what's the question
did you calculate the dimension of the
garbage on the boundary that
well
it's i mean it's this proposition is
game over for shifted partial
derivatives
okay so we don't need to worry about
them anymore but we can use them as a
starting point just as the method of
partial derivatives was used as a
starting point for shifted partials and
you can get a lot more out of shifted
partials than partials if we use this as
our starting point maybe we can go
further
yeah probably good to say that in
general you know these particular
complexity measures have some intuition
but
any linear mechanism as well it may come
from that's what i'm about to say
you can you guys are way ahead of me and
um
yeah so
the case you are going to say this
the advantage of using a linear map in
the context of algebraic circuits lower
bound is that of course this measures
that
it's sub-additive i agree
and yeah all of them would be like that
that's correct in some cases like they
shifted
like the power shells and sometimes the
shifts that are also closed up the
multiplication yes and uh for that
reason they serve as a natural
complexity measure for arithmetic
circuits that's what you're doing
multiplying
so we can you know
invent things very different than than
this and the question what what's the
limit of anything now maps
yes that is what i was planning to say
but thank you you said it better than i
could which leader might i'm talking
about well here is he showed you two the
path as the partial derivative and the
shifted partial now he has a new subject
so let me
let me actually
yeah so
um
tamiani and i were studying
wearing rank of polynomials or wearing
border rank of polynomials
and um
we
introduced a method that generalized
existing techniques at the time that is
to say flattenings or catalectic hints
and the idea
i'll give you a very explicit example in
a moment so you embed your space of
polynomials
so again when we're looking for
modules of equations we're looking for g
l
v modules
and those are given by part part at
least the polynomial ones i i'll write
as s pi v where pi is a partition
so
what this should be is we need to embed
our space of polynomials inside the
space of linear maps
from
some module to another
this will work
where pi tilde is formed
from
pi
by adding
n
boxes no two
in the same
column
this is the pierry rule that tells you
that this is sort of all the possible
things so let's given a polynomial
let's let p pi
pi tilde be the resulting linear map
right
and again the rank of this linear map is
a measure of the complexity of the
polynomial p
so let's do
just the first example partial
derivatives
so your first so v will be cn
capital n
um
so for partial derivatives you start off
with a diagram that looks like this
which is n minus 1
by n minus k box
that's pi
and then uh i'll do
pi tilde i got to add some boxes to that
so i'll add
i need to add
n boxes
so this is n minus k
so i add the n boxes here
and this
module as far as polynomials are
concerned this is all trivial for the
special linear group so this thing i
might as well consider like this
which is
some k of v
any
is any vector space sufficiently large
dimension that i don't get zero
b n is dimensional capital n is
dimension
so i have to pick my pi
based on n
and if i do shifted partials let me just
use the same picture for shifted
partials the picture is exactly the same
except i start out a little further and
so then
here i get sk plus t
so i still add on in boxes but
so shifted
also falls into this framework
but um
we were thinking about wearing rank
it's not so little that is much bigger
than
beget to prove a theorem
but you can define it for any value of t
i'm just talking about weird and also to
prove a theorem about something you care
about you want to have t that size but
to prove a theorem that mathematicians
care about you may not want to have t
that size okay this is i mean i
understand that mathematics only exists
to serve computer science but sometimes
we entertain ourselves with our own
little questions
that you know
even if no one else cares we like them
so um
let me what does one do is both a
mathematician and a computer scientist i
want to
let's
let's let's talk about this let me
finish this lecture
um i i'm going to try and break
tradition and not run over by 10 minutes
uh
but i doubt i don't know the depends on
how many questions but more questions
the better and we'll just live with it
so remember when i talked about
this um hilbert
function or this hilbert flattening i'm
going to call it now
it was absolutely useless
for um wearing rank because when you're
looking at a d an n power this map is
injective
so we would never
think about that
if we're studying wearing rank
but
there if if you want to get the most
juice you go to the other extreme
and we looked at this map
sim n minus k
v star tensor lambda q v
so first we did the same thing
two sim
kv
tensor lambda qv nothing happens and
then we take well is it i'm i was born
in mathematics as a differential
geometer so i think of this as exterior
derivative
or a kazoo map if
you want
uh to sim k minus 1v
tensor lambda q plus one v
so let's call this p k n minus k wedge
wedge q
so where d of some polynomial q tensor
y1 wedge wedge yq
is just the summation over the partial
derivatives
i'm going to be a little sloppy now but
you'll get the
yqyq
okay
so here
pie tilde
after you prune so there's so this map
should be pruned because there's stuff
that's mandatory kernel and the good
part of that that map is comes from the
partition k1 to the q
and this is roughly
for as far as wearing rank is concerned
two times better
than partial derivatives
so
it was possible to prove some new things
about
wearing rank
well so you remember those lower bounds
so we're comparing and wearing rank
we're comparing
how many we want to write a polynomial p
as a sum of nth powers and we want to
get a lower bound for that number
of nth powers that we need using
flattening's or partial derivative
method we got a bound
basically the rank of that flattening
map
and basically here you can potentially
get about twice as good of a bound
okay and you do get about twice as good
of a bound so as far as computer science
is concerned that's not you know
so serious yet but
let's uh continue nonetheless
and uh
so now though
the new game plan
uh
so this d is it exactly the daram
yes exactly
exactly that's why i called it exterior
derivative
and here i mean even though so sk b
tensor st should it be thought of as
differential operators with polynomial
coefficients you may if you like but
let's
well actually here
you want a differential operator with
polynomial coefficients this is the
differential operator with polynomial
coefficients
yeah good
good so but to se so so now the goal
becomes
the short term goal
goal is find
pi
and pi tilde
such the determinant
i
pi tilde has low rank
right if this linear map has low rank
then you can hopefully prove that
something is more generic than the
determinant
oh
uh
but
yeah so
right
so um my student cameron farnsworth
has been working on this
and so i i like to call this one the
kazul
flattening and um
he showed that this cazool
flattening
in fact the determinant
is more generic
so
as a mathematical result this is very
interesting but
um
you're more generic
more well so you you get a better lower
bound on the border rank of the
determinant from a casual flattening
than you get from a usual flattening
so
that in itself is not a disaster
but at the same time he proved that the
permanent
um is
also more generic but
of the same order of magnitude and
sometimes even worse
since i'll just take two seconds to
mention a crazy conjecture by a crazy
guy gervitz who actually conjectures
that the wearing rank of the determinant
should be actually lower than the
wearing rank of the permanent and
somehow that explains why the
determinant is easy to compute and the
permanent heart
so this is evidence for garbage's
conjecture
uh and he's a serious guy even even
though
yeah it's that conjecture sounds strange
but it is actually not unreasonable
but i don't have time for that so that
one's no good so i should mention a a
recent very exciting result
by uh luke oding
and
han
um
sorry i shouldn't
han and oding uh which used the
staircase
and then they showed a new lower bound
on the rank
of
this x1 dot dot xn remember the old
was 2 to the n over square root of n and
they got the sharp result which is um
one half 2 to the n otherwise known as 2
to the n minus 1 but they got rid of the
square root of n
is no queue here they used the staircase
this they did not use this is pi
staircase
what is the staircase the staircase
partition
this is
i can't draw it so well
um and and then and then farnsworth
tried the staircase
and you got the same thing
same phenomena as as with the kazoo for
the determinant so um i should say
though that the determinant just on
oh that's coming in the last part of the
talk
that for this for this hilbert map
though the determinant
is
less generic than the permanent just not
as much as we want and i also want to
say that this indicates that we're going
to need
there's some
limit of this method
and there's only two examples
i know of geometrically defined
equations that do not fit into this
method
one was the one that this lecture
started with
um but that's those are still
determinantal equations just the entries
in the determinant are not linear forms
but polynomials and the coefficients but
there's these equations due to brill
for exactly the orbit closure of this x1
up to xn
that are geometrically defined and go
beyond this so the linearity is good
for all the reasons avi said which is
what i was going to say now but it's bad
that it seems to have an inherent limit
and we have some examples in geometry
that go beyond that so one is brill's
equations and um so uh
yanghui guan
um is doing some interesting work
generalizing bruhl's equations in a way
see because of their non-linearity you
can't just use them uh at subadditively
but he's working on a variation that
will enable that
so exactly
addresses the two questions you posed
yeah go ahead ivy just a comment if you
just want to get actually not up to the
end but two to the end for the monomial
you can get much more simply you
restricted yourself to partial
derivatives okay i
what this is bruhl's equations are for
the chow variety they are not
of this form but they are determinantal
and i think those are the
in my personal opinion sort of brill's
equations are the best path to sort of
breaking this inherent limit of the
linearity
but that's a personal opinion i guess
everything is a personal opinion all
right so
this transform result
is
farnsworth results two different
partitions
one is the hook
that otavi and i were using and one is
the staircase in both cases they each
give lower bounds on the wearing border
rank of the determinant
and unfortunately the determinant is
like super
super charged
for those in that its rank does not drop
by much for the extra map
so
it's for for the permanent versus
determinant it's not so good but
this this
well the model of this model i would say
is a better picture
well so he did two things he replaced
this sk by lambda k
but then there's something more
complicated inspired by the han owning
result replacing it by a staircase so
there's two results
okay
right
so um the hilbert function
one way you can compute it is as the
euler characteristic of a minimal free
resolution of an ideal and so you get
much more information
um
if you do that
so i'm going to write it sort of
representation theoretically since i'm
almost out of time
well since i am technically out of time
i'm just going to start saying things
instead of writing them
so um yurji vaiman's talk told us that
if you can compute a minimal rev free
resolution you can get a lot of good
information
uh so this
is the so in so now this we have this
ideal eye that i was talking about in
our case it's the ideal generated by
partial derivatives and these are the
generators so you're resolving s
well
it's the same thing right
okay i mean
i could
not exceed by i yeah
okay so here these are the first
relations among the generators
the gen the the uh
a basis
a module
of relations
and um
the larger
so the larger this is
means our ideal is more pathological
that's not quite true that's only if you
fix
the generate fix the size of the
generators
and then
the more relations you have the more
pathological
so um
a quick example
they is e tensor
f
then m1
so
we're looking for path ways of proving a
polynomial is pathological so if we fix
so we take partial derivatives we get an
ideal if we fix the dimension of the
space of partial derivatives then we
want something that's more subtle than
that right so once you fix that size the
next measure of pathology is the size of
this vector space which is the relations
so if if we're starting with the
determinant
uh so i is the size
generated by
by size k minors
then the laplace expansions
uh give us linear relations if i take a
k by k k plus 1 by k
sub matrix
and then i repeat
uh
a row to make it k
so i repeat this last row
i have a k plus one by k plus one sub
matrix whose determinant is zero i form
like a tensor laplace expansion where
and i put the um
linear form here and the size k minors
in the expansion here when i map it over
here i get 0 because i erase the tensor
product
and
so that's the kind of thing and so we
have a lot of linear relations here for
the determinant since i'm out of time
it's too bad i wanted to talk about
so first of all lascu computed this
completely
and veymon made it even very explicit in
his book
um
he views it as just to exercise but i
read
lasko's paper and it's a
it's a challenging exercise um
it's very explicit in terms of modules
it's
for the size k minors and so it's it's
basically these things are generated by
hooks of various sizes where the hook is
long
and um
our the unique proposition which i'm
only going to state vaguely since time
has been up
is that for the permanent
um the sub permanent
size k
um these mjs so these these are the mjs
are all look like this
um the mjs contain
hooks but now i have to tell you what
these hooks are we no longer have the
gen the special linear group we have the
permutation group so these are hooks now
are modules for the permutation group
and the hooks you get here
which are modules for the permutation
group are the transposes of the hooks
you get here in the linear strand
so
it contains those
and um
reconjecture
that
in fact that's exactly the linear strand
and um yorji has some ideas how to
prove that conjecture and the
the point is now that we can exactly
compute
at least um not too far into the minimal
free resolution we have exact formulas
for
this hilbert function
of the ideal generated by the sub
permanence up until a certain point and
that's why it's work in progress
we hope someday to get the whole
resolution about the permanent that will
give us
a lot more information about the
permanent and then we could because the
permanent is not a generic polynomial
uh but we need to know that in some kind
of coordinate freeway
to have invariants
that
will enable us to separate determinant
from permanent thank you for your time
there's a concept for these differences
with five different calculations
because it comes for the all-terrain
binomial yeah that's exactly
yeah it's and it's every step along the
way
yeah
sorry
the question is
is it the fiber because you you are
looking for
zlm square environments uh
all the miners of the run for all these
linear maps
are direct square environments by
construction well they're mod no they're
modules they're they're they're
they're modules they're not invariants
yes
so anything in the gln squared
yeah the spaces
so that's we want to extract numerical
information from this geometric picture
yeah so this method including your
exterior
thing
how much do you think you can push can
you go beyond this choir or
are you unclear where you can go
no i doubt okay so maybe
just maybe we could sort of tie the
world record
maybe even a little bit beyond that but
it's
it's going to be game over soon after
that
but
but
this is not the end of the story this is
not
you know this is i think the end of the
story for determinants of matrices who
have linear entries in the polynomials
and one's going to have to deal with
i think one can still stay in the
context of determinant ideals but you
have to go to matrices where the entries
are not no longer linear that's going to
make life much worse
for the reasons i'll be explained but i
don't think we have a choice if we want
a geometric construction of these
modules
in some perspective our reason was not
just to study determined versus
permanent the real reason was to able to
understand like different complexity
classes and even determined is not the
unique polynomial is complete for class
p
so there are many other polynomials and
if you write down them they have
different geometry it's very interesting
to study with different polynomials but
like determinant is a good starting
point to do to do this calculations
because it's kind of relatively easy and
relatable
that's only computer scientists could
have that optimism prank
what's the dimension of the varieties
i i told you
oh oh oh that's open
that's open we only know it in the
extreme cases and even then so we know
it for like k equals two and three
and
and n minus one everyone in the world
believes that it's co-dimension n but
i've not seen anyone write down a proof
of it
one of the things i mean you're a map of
the entire part of the river
but if you look at
right one of the things one of the
things on our table which i did not have
time to mention is one way to merge
these two techniques is to tensor this
thing with the kazoo complex and then
look at that that resolution
yes
that's on that's that's on the plate but
the plate is already very full as you
know
we want to first kind of do as much as
we can with the so-called easy case
before we move on to the
uh even more ridiculously hard
cases of certain secant varieties yes
those that we checked always vanished on
a linear strands of arbitrary schemes of
the same
bounded length okay
we'll have to discuss that offline
no that's another way of saying i don't
know
i want to say completely
you know
there is a lot of information that we
know permanent has been studied for
various other
permanent has been studied substantially
but its algebraic geometry is extremely
poorly understood instead i just wonder
so you know the what thunder valden's
congestion the big achievement and we
now have two separate proofs for this
there's pegman's upper bound
two things have nothing to do with each
other i find it a little hard to believe
no i know that i can offer a way of
making contact between
and how to believe that well so already
it's been there's tons and tons of
literature on the determinant even
going back right and to convert that to
information you can use in this setting
is not i mean we've
there's been some effort expended on
that already for the determinant and
when when you get to the permanent
you're in combinatorics and if you want
to win this game you have to avoid
combinatorics because that will that
will just i mean
well explicit combinatorics you could
only do asymptotic combinatorics i
should say it that way
and that you know like here when when we
study representations of permutation
group you have to understand the
asymptotics of those representations
not you know
we
like schwa was talking yesterday we were
just trying to find out if one stupid
looking module is in the ideal of the
orbit closure of the determinant this
basically the simplest thing you can
describe we can't even do that and when
we tried we got face up to alone tarsy
and all these other horrible conjectures
or beautiful conjectures that no one
knows how to solve so so one has to kind
of try and avoid that somehow
okay
yeah
hey
um